il entend c'est ce que dit aujourd'hui
je trouve sur bbc oui je sais pas
comment ça se dit en français postier h
saint jules en fait on va construire et
catapulte pour péter des choses voilà
qui voit de plus en plus du rap et et
c'est parti à comme ça ok eaux
s'écoulent à il mais après un petit peu
à jouer c'est ça donc je construis ma
[ __ ] je peux tourner à oui biensur
aller et ça c'est fait a ensuite vous
prendre des roustes à elles émettent de
parts et d'autres
oui monsieur l'est nous aide pas comme
il faut et ensuite on va devoir bien se
démerder attention est ce que ça marche
est ce qu'on va casser la petite maison
dans la prairie oui monsieur alors pas
on veut parler au futur la casse nous
pas dans ça se passe mal je casse tout
cas faut casser ça et est ce qu'elle est
suffisante pour casser ça à banon et
c'est quoi le truc du milieu zara quazar
farouk
c'est juste pour faire joli c'est un
métronome y avait un moyen de voler mecs
m'ont fait ça tout de suite pourquoi ne
m'avait pas prévenu la lah et là est
absolument partout sur cette pittoresque
à taper est-ce que vous êtes prêts c'est
parti allez on n'a pas tourné envole toi
un tout petit peu voilà non la déception
en fait c'est le tuto au début qui m'a
induit en erreur
moi je suis ingénieur dans la vie et je
sais que finalement le mieux à faire oui
de matières ou directement l'ars est de
mettre ce petit truc qui pivote et voilà
hélas normand pourra tourner du coup
aller aussi bon bien dégagée bouton
[ __ ] on reste compliqué là on a créé
un truc incroyable
attention la dite montrent où elle est
présente là tous décédés dans
l'explosion
j'ai très vieux mouton pierre bailleul
et si on fait carrément un détour énorme
en mode on n'a pas le temps ah pardon à
dos rond on finit à deux roues on n'a
pas le temps mais oui c'est bien mieux
comme ça au nord il ya un problème mais
un problème de pilosité pas du tout on
est un [ __ ] blog tetris ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta ta royal où résiste à on en met
deux d'un coup ça va quoi j'avais
fabriqué de moto c'est parti non mais on
y croyait on est à fond la dame tam tam
tam tam
alors elle pas bien moto médiévale et
des archives est catho mais le mieux
c'est de faire une petite moto blindés
la blindés édition à l'épreuve des
flèches et voilà [ __ ] situe à faire
je suis blindé
vas-y tire t flèche aaaah ça me fait
rigoler faut casser ça le deuxième au
monde et en os à part d'attraction que
la fed fera le succès comme ça mais pas
de quoi je parle hop là ça c'est un mec
veut s'asseoir au cas où sur la salle
basse et le siège de la moto finalement
c'est plus confortable il paraît on n'a
pas le temps
oui effectivement allez on se ressemble
en tout cas dit on à un [ __ ] de crédit
ou y est eu à faire mon gars on est
encore nous dans l'ain dans le milieu
c'est parti or cette j'ai pas trop aller
bonjour j'ai mis des plaques absolument
partout où je vais faire quoi après sa
seconde houari on en faire quoi
attention là c'est du très lourd
ok après 28 millions d'années nous avons
réussi à construire l'engin parfait et
je vois à la montée surprise quoi ça les
fait rire mon gars alors je suis trône
et brûle je n'y croyais plus en ex sru
ça va en faire une machine de dingue tu
es 90% des gens alors déjà j'ai une
sacrée idée en tête armel à l'aller
pauvre j'aimerais pas être à ma place je
vous le dis hein j'aimerais pas être à
ma place parce que là sur le côté ya
quoi bah il faut acheter un bloc lance
flammes et lance flammes viendra des
flammes partout
est-ce qu'on n'est pas bien là je vous
attends vasif les biens tous autour
n'ose plus abondants fois encore alors
on a voulu faire quoi dans le viage
touvet voulu faire toi touch est tombé
sur le volet et délivré deux iron ore cc
gros truc là crois que mon véhicule
n'est pas très approprié mais bon va
tester à l'est j'active les flammes
alors nous allons repartir sur une
structure très original qui change
vraiment beaucoup de la toute première
qu'on a fait la spa râler un peu juste à
le pousser
ben voilà et 2 1 et le deuxième un merle
fallu un petit canon pour le shooter sa
déception qui s'empare de nos pôles de
santé aux gars gens que ça a tout cassé
quand je vais tirer au nom tout ça ça
dégage
et qu'est ce qu'on va mettre un truc qui
nous permet de nous envoler je pense à
ce mode est pas du tout là mais bon je
fais attention au plus tard dit
d'arrêter mais qui ont des [ __ ]
d'arrêter des questions à faire mais
voilà on est bien là et je fais comment
pour me diriger bas au niveau feeling on
y va au moins on peut voler à est déjà
en vol ok tu que tu critiques -
catapulte mais qu'est ce qu'elle fait un
tabac critique la maison non c'est pas
du tout comme ça qu'on fait pour
l'éviter au oui
oh oh oh c'était orgasmique qui vient de
se passer
tu te crois mali mais quoi au nom mais
les pistons paule baussan alors là c'est
du grand art se plaindre mal franco
c'était incroyable combien de faire
plutôt chic pour vous c'est petit pour
moi c'est un grand pas pour l'homme
oye faut faire quoi là faut détruire ce
truc bâton des nous ont pris pour qui tu
te crois au téléphone qu'elle ait ou non
une traîne de ses passes exellent ce
qu'ont fait ou le tente
ok cette fois on est nul
baky c'est pas ça et manque un bloc bas
bien en même temps c'est un mec piège
mon véhicule comment je fais quoi tu vas
voir tu vas pas volé mon gars ou quoi
non mais tu voi avec moi tu veulent pas
tout seul albi h
alors non toujours toi oh je le savais
qu'on pouvait le faire je le savais
utilisent des explosifs pour détruire
40% paris au lancement mais quelque
chose mais je sais pas regardez-moi ça
elle ça va être du génie si ça marche
c'est du génie s'étaient habitués du
génie quand on croit pas amenam ne fait
pas tout péter direct aussi nommé fdp
bobek j'appuie sur une touche pour faire
tomber des cuves du coup la boule s'en
aller comme ça comme talent
amenez moi devant le roi que je respecte
et son [ __ ] de château je suis prêt
détruisez 90% de tous les chevaliers les
tentes et les canons mais y'a aucun
problème
allez on y va voilà on va faire une
véritable machine de guerre biatch et
vous allez voir vous allez très surpris
par cette véritable machine de guerre
cette architecture digne des plus grand
bordel alors est-ce que sa route jusqu'à
ce que les roues elle assume oui oui
sourire oui je sais que du bois fait ça
les défenses complètement mais moi ça je
me rendrai à faire un choix [ __ ] de
rubik's cube mais je défonce tout à
l'été ce qui se passe on y va au haut
débit dans un ananas dans la merde
problème nul ce prime à la casse toi toi
pouah pouah pouah pouah font foi leurs
femmes osagi oignons ton blanc flammes
dans le q qu'est ce qui se passe kong à
aller là c'est bon voilà
j'aime leur faible un peu aller là c'est
bon détruit 80 % au niveau du mans j'ai
une idée j'ai une idée j'ai une idée
c'est un one shot show ça marche ou ça
marche pas du tout et vous avez toutes
les raisons pour croire ça paye tout
marche et puis en fait si on arrive à
voilà à surélever un peu et le monument
il va pas il va pas réussir à ça à vivre
j'ai du mal à parler bordel
oh oui parfait en position en possession
aux mecs aux arrêts à temps mais beck
mais c'est juste trop sur quoi je
connais pas en position mordelles les
officiers ont été détruits 80% de la
tour c'est parti est ce que je veux
faire une vraie catapulte on va faire un
petit test
voilà il ya la boule c'est bien mais
maintenant comment l'envoyait ça la
vraie question comme ça c'est parce
qu'il me semblait ça ne marche pas
est-ce que ça ouais ça mec ça peut
marcher mon gars ça a l'air totalement
ridicule comme ça mais ça peut marcher
attendez vous allez voir à j'ai une idée
formidable trait à vous savez bien que
c'est de la folie ce qui se passe
regardez du coup c'est bien pencher un
peu en avant mais ça fait tout péter et
bada les steaks
cette boule elle est trop dangereuse
quoi que faire que faire et regarder ça
en plus c'est beau brun que le voir
faire ça c'est joli c'est mignon comme
ça un mec au
c'est une chance ratée ma couille ce
prime à deux fautes non il faut ouest
une vraie catapulte là je suis sûr qu'à
mourir comme ça ressemble à ça je pense
faut juste que tout vent moyen de ça ça
se balance comme sa double force à merde
attendait au et et et alors là moi 900
cas au nom banon mais je suis
complètement con du coup y'a pas les
petits démons gars il faut ajouter des
blocs là c'est scandaleux ce travail
[Musique]
et voilà gens c'est sur cette superbe
catapulte construit termine parce que je
suis encore coûtant soit sympa de faire
un petit jeu de construction comme ça
pour une fois ça vous a plu n'hésitez
pas aimé la vidéo comme d'habitude le
lien de jouer dans la description se
retrouve très vite dans une nouvelle
attaque apple on croit même savoir
garder à son tour très vite dans une
nouvelle vidéo chat ou bis à tampa vont
rassembler pour faire un tas de gens nus
pour être ça ça vous seront chères privé
et voilà on a constitué une véritable
orgie sur la plage est interdite
[Musique]